ja hallo annina hier ist weit die
theorie und ich würde gerne von dir
wissen wie deine familie damit zurecht
kommt dass du
pornos liest ja also meine familie kommt
er mittlerweile mit mittlerweile sehr
gut mit zu recht dass ich pornofilme
gedreht habe für meine mutter war es am
anfang sehr sehr schwierig also als ich
gesagt habe ich stehe jetzt in die
erotikbranche ein hat sie gesagt okay
gibt mir ein paar tage zeit
aber sie steht zu 100 prozent hinter mir
gerade für eine mutter ist natürlich
schwierig aber sie sich die zu 100
prozent hinter mir und wir haben
eigentlich würde ich auch ein sehr
freundschaftliches verhältnis